en los cuatro vídeos pasados analizamos
qué pasaba con las ecuaciones
diferenciales de segundo orden que
fueran lineales y homogéneas y además
tuvieran coeficientes constantes y si
recuerdan tenían esta forma a por jerry
prima más b por i prima más c por james
y cómo era homogénea pues lo teníamos
que igualar a cero
abc eran constantes también obtendríamos
la ecuación a r cuadrada más r
y a esto le sumábamos y lo iguala vamos
a 0 y la llamábamos la ecuación
característica asociada a la ecuación
diferencial y de esta ecuación
buscábamos sus raíces si estas raíces
fueran reales es decir si ere fuera r1 y
r2 las cuales fueran reales pues
entonces yo ya pueden escribir mi
solución general de esta ecuación de
segundo grado
una ecuación general me quedaba de la
forma si se acuerdan ye igual a una
constante 1 que multiplicaba ha elevado
a la r1 por x a mi primer raíz por x más
c 2 por ea la r2 por x mi segunda raíz
por x todo esto lo hemos analizado con
mucha calma en los vídeos pasados así
que si tienen alguna duda sería bueno
que recurran a esos vídeos que hemos
realizado bien pero seguramente ustedes
se van a preguntar qué pasa si esta
ecuación asociada tiene raíces que no
sean reales y eso lo que vamos a ver en
este vídeo pero primero lo que voy a
hacer es escribir a toda esa ecuación de
segundo grado de la fórmula general que
nosotros no sabíamos de álgebra es decir
menos b mayúscula más menos la raíz
cuadrada de b cuadrada
- cuatro veces a porsche y todo esto
estaba dividido entre dos a ojo estoy
usando las letras mayúsculas porque son
los coeficientes constantes de mi
ecuación diferencial de segundo orden
otra cosa que quiero ver es que con esta
fórmula nosotros estamos las dos raíces
pero ahora la pregunta es qué pasa si b
cuadrada menos 4 hace esto es negativo y
bien si supongo que es lo que está
dentro de mi raíz es negativo pues
entonces voy a tener un número
imaginario y entonces un número
imaginario más un número real pues me da
un número complejo miren yo voy a
escribir de otra manera para que quede
más claro me lo va a escribir como menos
b entre 2 a más menos la raíz cuadrada
de b cuadrada menos 4 hace todo eso
entre 2 a hasta aquí todo va muy bien y
darse cuenta que el segundo sumando el
que tenemos aquí es un número imaginario
porque voy a cuadrada menos 4 ac es
negativo y pues la raíz de un número
negativo es un número imaginario y es
quédense cuenta que como yo divide
si a mis dos sumandos se ve claramente
que r es un número complejo porque vamos
a tener una parte real y una parte
imaginaria además las dos raíces r1 y r2
del polinomio característico van a ser
complejas con jugadas pero bien entonces
solo entremos al escenario de las raíces
complejas vamos a escribir a r de una
forma que nos simplifica más las cosas
recuerden que r es nuestras dos raíces
complejas a r la voy a escribir de la
forma lambda la anda la letra griega
debido a la convención muchas personas
usan la letra lambda para la parte real
lambda va a ser menos b / 2a es una
forma más fácil de ponerlo ok ya esto le
voy a sumar más menos y voy a usar otras
letras y esta vez voy a utilizar la
letra new la cual también voy a usar por
convención ustedes pueden poner de
cualquier letra que ustedes quieran pero
tengan cuidado mío es un número real es
por eso que lo voy a multiplicar
y por la raíz de menos 1 para que así ya
tenga mis dos raíces una raíz lambda más
new y otra raíz lambda menos miope es
decir que me datos raíces complejas y
con jugadas bien ahora qué va a pasar si
sustituyó a r pero recuerden que r son
dos raíces entonces cuando yo vea a r 1
voy a poner a lambda más mi wii y cuando
vea a r2 voy a poner a lambda - new y
entonces sustituyendo que me va a quedar
y va a ser igual a c1 por el elevado la
primera raíz a ere uno entonces me queda
lambda más mi y elevado a la lambda más
new y todo eso x x ya esto le voy a
sumar una constante 2 que multiplica a
la exponencial otra vez pero a la
elevada a la segunda raíz lambda menos
new y todo esto por x
bien ahora lo que voy a hacer es
distribuir la multiplicación por x esto
me va a ayudar a escribir mi expresión
de una manera mucho más amigable
así que utilicemos algo de manipulación
algebraica para que nos quede algo mucho
más manejable bien escribiremos ahí
ahora de la forma c 1 que multiplica
yo lo voy a distribuir la multiplicación
y elevado a la lambda x + x por y más
una constante 2 que multiplica a en
elevado y otra vez distribuyó la
multiplicación elevado a la lambda x -
new x que multiplica a y 10 en este
momento donde voy a utilizar las leyes
de los exponentes voy a recordar que a a
la n por aa la m es lo mismo que a a la
n más m y utilizamos la propiedad pueden
escribir ayer de la forma uno por el ala
lambda x
por el ala mío x y esto utilizando las
leyes de los exponentes recuerdan que
esto sería igual a sumar los exponentes
más c 2 y de manera análoga a la lambda
x que multiplica a la función
exponencial elevada a la menos 1000 x y
pero no estoy haciendo esto de gratis
quiero que se den cuenta que ahora ya
tengo un factor común y factor común es
a la lambda x entonces lo voy a
factorizar que me va a quedar
bien
es igual a el ala lambda x muy bien que
va a multiplicar a una constante 1 por
el ala mil x
muy bien y a esto le voy a sumar una
constante de 2 que multiplica al
exponencial elevada al amigo equis y
negativo y es justo aquí donde las cosas
se van a poner muy divertidas porque si
ustedes se acuerdan de los vídeos que yo
les había puesto en la serie de cálculo
había unos vídeos de series que se
aproximan a otras funciones y de hecho
había un vídeo de la serie que se
aproximaba a la exponencial recuerda que
el exponencial es una de las más
maravillosas funciones que existen
matemáticas justo aquí es cuando nos
vamos a utilizar porque tenemos una
exponencial elevada a un número
imaginario y si ustedes se acuerdan yo
esto lo podría resolver usando la
fórmula de hoy leer la fórmula de hoy
les decía así lo voy a poner demorado
para que se vea muy importante y decía
que he elevado a la y x era coseno de x
más veces seno de x esta identidad de
hoy leer es una identidad sorprendente
porque tiene que ver con una exponencial
vista desde una combinación de senos y
cosenos por ejemplo si nosotros
sustituimos axn esta expresión por pi me
da de resultado la identidad de oyler
es igual a menos 1 y esto se puede ver
cuando sustituyamos x por pi pero
inclusive le podemos poner otro valor a
x no sé supongamos 2000e elevado a las 2
p por y pues sería igual a coseno de dos
primas y veces seno de 2 p o sea 1 esta
fórmula magnífica salía de evaluar a l x
como serie de potencias y realmente era
casi una definición pues cuando nosotros
poníamos la serie de potencias de x nos
daba igual a la serie de potencias del
coseno de x + y veces la serie de
potencias del seno de x ahora bien que
si no recuerdan de dónde sale esta
identidad pueden
buscar los vídeos sobre la función
exponencial elevada a la y x pero bueno
es momento de utilizar esta identidad de
hoy leer para nuestra solución general
de esta manera me va a quedar igual a la
lambda x al alam de x porque ya lo
habíamos factor izado que va a
multiplicar a mi primer constante a la
constante c 1 que multiplica a su vez a
la mil x y pero esto por la fórmula de
boiler ya lo podemos sustituir por
consejo de mi x más veces el seno de new
x esto por nuestra fórmula de oyler ya
esto hay que agregarle la segunda
expresión c2a a la menos mi x
pero con la fórmula de valer me queda
más c 2 coseno y en esta ocasión va a
ser de menos 1000 x porque es negativo
nuestro exponente bien ya esto le
tenemos que sumar pues y veces el seno
de menos mil x perfecto ahora lo que
sigue es hacer un poco de limpieza sobre
esta expresión sin embargo para ya no
hacer este vídeo más extenso yo creo que
lo mejor será dejarlo para el que sigue
así que no se lo pierdan y nos vemos en
el siguiente